SOLUTION.
IT'S GETTING A LOT BIGGER THAN
THEY ARE.EREK GRANT WAS THERE T
UP THINGS UP IN THE REBOUND BUT
IT WAS REALLY ABOUT
USE THE TERM FREE AGENCY
AND AROUND THEY GO AND AND
JOSI.
I THINK THAT IT IS A STICK.
WAS.
UP ON THE BRUSH IT IS DRYSDALE.
AND HE LEADS THE PREDATORS WHAT
THAT DOESN'T P ACROSS AND MAKES
THE INITIAL STOP ON THE REBOUND
AND THAT  OFF THE MARK AND CARR
GOES BACK INTO HISMIDDLE
AND HE IS SCORED WIDE BY SAM
STEELE. THA LEAD.
RIGHT NOW WE
>> A GREAT PLAY BY DRYSDALE TO
WORTH THAT CHANCE ANDSOFT PLAY .
HERE IS THEIT OFF THE
KICK PLATE.
BACK TO THE
HE IS PENALTY IS OVER A AND YOU
THE NET.
NOT ONLY IS THIS IMPRESSIV TRIC
DUCKS
CLAIRE OFF THE SKATE AND
AND SKATES AROUND AND THAT'S TH
SECOND